[Music]
in our series i on earth we're looking
at what could be an unusual weapon in
the battle against climate change
seaweed that's right seaweed the richest
man on the planet amazon founder jeff
bezos
is betting big on it his 10 billion
climate fund that's with a b
awarded 100 million dollars to study and
develop seaweed as a sustainable crop on
a warming planet
as ben tracy shows us it could also be a
way to trap
harmful carbon emissions that are
causing climate change
it's morning in maine
and matt moretti is cutting through a
heavy blanket of fog
what's it like driving out here in a
morning like this oh it's incredibly
disorienting really
hard to see just as it starts to clear
we see dozens of these colorful buoys
bobbing on the water
we've arrived at his underwater farm
[Applause]
his crop is seaweed the fancy name for
it
is kelp
we sent a diver down to see what it
looks like below
growing on these thousand foot long
lines now could you just eat this right
now
yeah you want to try some sure yeah
yeah give it a nibble it's delicious
cheers
that's actually pretty good thanks for
sharing your kelp absolutely
moretti and 24 other seaweed farmers in
maine
sell their kelp to bree warner back in
portland you know it's really fun to say
i run a seaweed company her company
atlantic sea farms
turns it into food products sold in
grocery stores and
increasingly restaurants at this one in
maine the lobster roll is topped with
seaweed pesto
how quickly is this growing here so the
entire state of maine in 2018 was 40 000
pounds and this year we'll be harvesting
us alone two years later 850 thousand
pounds
seaweed which has been popular in asian
countries for generations
is considered a healthy source of
protein with up to five times more
calcium than milk
and it's a crop that might better
withstand climate change
worldwide seaweed production is on pace
to be bigger than potatoes
by 2051. seaweed is not the most
celebrated of plants
in the ocean people think oh it's that
thing that wraps around your legs when
you're swimming
we met paul dobbins from the world
wildlife fund in the middle of casco bay
part of the gulf of maine which is
warming faster than 99 percent of the
earth's oceans
partly because of how shallow it is the
warmer water is causing some fish
species to head north
and could eventually threaten maine's
main export
lobster and this is a way to create a
vegetable and a protein source
that doesn't require the fresh water or
the land or
fertilizer which is really kind of
miraculous
well this is our sea water facility but
scientists like nicole price
think seaweed has a lot more to offer
seaweed
might be having a moment yeah yeah i
would say seaweed's having
a moment yeah blow her away early
results from her team's experiment show
seaweed farms
dramatically improve water quality and
absorb one of the main greenhouse gases
warming our planet seaweed's a great
sponge
for carbon dioxide our cars power plants
factories and farms
all pump carbon dioxide into the air the
world's oceans absorb about one-third of
those emissions
so far helping the planet avoid even
more catastrophic changes
scientists already know that sea grass
and mangroves absorb carbon even better
than the world's tropical rainforests do
which when they burn pump all that
stored carbon back into the air
so this gives us a good ray of hope for
a future world where the seaweed seems
to be
able to take what we can give it in
terms of carbon dioxide wow
for lobstermen like steve train who also
started farming kelp this year
it's a hedge against an uncertain future
right now we're heavily dependent on one
resource
so if there is a turn in the fishery
there needs to be something else and
right now kelp was one of those things
one of those things that's so much more
than the stuff tangled
around our feet for cbs this morning ben
tracy
off the coast of maine bigger than
potatoes by 2051. that was
honestly they are delicious as potato
chips there's the type of seaweed you
get as a snack they sell it at like
every corner store in new york kids love
it
find it in your local supermarket i
recommend it and it tastes good too it
tastes good
it gets all in your teeth just but it's
getting your teeth and make them eat it
outside because you'll be picking out of
the rug for about a decade
but i like what ben said seaweed is
having a moment and all the things you
could do seaweed pesto who knew
i don't i don't think i don't think man
would recommend it raw off the boat but
you know with some processing
he ate that with some hesitation